barcelona that's where we are coming to
you um from today my name is david
manter for those of you who don't know
me and i'm here today with
look
we're with luca lampariello and we're
going to be talking about something that
i think is very interested in and that
is the relationship between language and
life
because i know that you know luca is
someone who inspires a lot of people
here on the internet and i've
you know looked at some of the
discussions i've seen online and i see
that a lot of people think that it
requires you know lots and lots and lots
of study in order to you know truly
become proficient in in any language um
but you know as luke and i have been
talking about today and i've also been
observing that's not sort of the way
that luca goes about doing things then
um before we jump into discussion about
you know how luca goes about doing
things then i thought i would ask you
you know look at what is the
relationship between
language and life well i would say the
language is life is a way of living life
we live life because we speak languages
otherwise we would not be able to
communicate with other people right
so i think that language is an integral
part of life
i wouldn't say it's life but it's an
integral part of life it's an integral
part of it's it's the instrument for
which we live
and so if you know by saying that it's
the instrument by which we live does
that mean then that in order to speak a
language well that you need to sort of
find ways to integrate it into your life
yeah absolutely
i think that
you know i don't study that much i i
tend to
distinguish between study and learn
because i tend to study maybe or learn a
little bit with language
learning material
such as
there's a lot of products on the market
anyway um but i don't i tend to stick to
uh
two books just very little three to six
months and then i you know as soon as i
um after three six months i get bored
and i i want to explore you know i want
to get out there and and use the
language
and i find ways to integrate the
language into my everyday life and that
changes everything i don't like the word
hard work when people say oh you work so
hard that's not true
you know it's it's i learn a lot but i
learned in the course of time and i
learned by
uh you know this is this is the point uh
the difference between i think that when
people say oh you're a genius it's not
it doesn't have to do anything to do
with being a genius or not it's like
some people know how to use uh when it
when you're learning something how to
make that something part of your life so
that's exactly what i do
that makes a huge difference if i stuck
just two books i wouldn't be able to
speak languages the way i do now it's
just because i use languages on a daily
basis and i found a way to do that i
decided to
to lead a certain life but also you also
can [ __ ] find ways that are proper
and they're they're good for you
a number of languages every single day
absolutely and you know this is you know
it makes me think about um you know
expats living in you know broadening
different countries because i um you
know i've observed hair in spain i've
been in spain for approximately a year
now and there are some people who come
here and in a short amount of time they
really develop their proficiency in a
language and others who stay here for a
long period of time but they don't and
the difference between the these two
type of people is not intelligent but
it's the amount to which they are they
have integrated themselves into the
culture and made um the language part of
their life intelligence has nothing to
do with it when people say i'm not in
time not smart enough to learn a
language or they say you're too smart
because you speak too many languages has
nothing to do with intelligence it has
to do with your human potential
everybody has a certain potential and
it's up to us to develop it um so and so
in this case um developing your
potential languages is the to the extent
to which you can really make it part of
your life and so
exactly you don't need to go to for
example when they say david speak to
spanish because you live in spain it's
not necessarily a concept but you know
living in spain doesn't make you a
fluent speaker you have to uh you have
to decide to make a
conscious effort to integrate not just
study the language but to make the
language part of your daily life because
people been living for 30 years in the
country they don't speak english and
there are people who live maybe six
months in a country and they go back to
their own country and they keep speaking
language native speakers mean because
they live with them or something else
happens well this is something i've
observed about you
um with languages because i notice in
one day you can switch between five six
seven different languages and it's um
it's not
something that you study it's not
something that you go to it's you know
it's part of your life and you know we
went to bars you know and it's just part
of your life where you just switch
between different languages and
you've developed a number of you know
deep relationships with different people
and so is this then also the trick to
you know maintaining all of these
languages as well because i think that
there are lots of people who think that
you have to study and study and study
for lots of time but but what is the
what's the truth you know how do you
live life with languages well the truth
is that um you know i
okay i work with languages i'm a
language coach so i work with languages
i use language
not teach how to learn but in the
language in a combination of languages
first i go out mostly with
borders even when i am in rome
so you know it's not a condition
you have to live in a foreign country
or i and i also live with
and obviously use languages on the
internet in general so that makes a huge
difference obviously
we have to consider the fact that we
have some strange sounds
well so the thing is that basically
it's
what makes a difference that i use
languages possibly on the internet in
real life in bars when i go out
with people i live and you know when you
live with somebody wake up and you have
an interesting conversation hey what did
you do yesterday or interesting
conversation in general what really
makes a difference
when you develop a certain level of
fluency is that on the one hand you
always have the same conversation how
you're doing et cetera et cetera but
when you develop that's that's what i
was talking about developing your human
potential because when you discover it's
also about connecting creating a strong
bond with people you really
and that motivates you pushes and pushes
you to have
to have interesting conversations
obviously the more interesting
conversations you have and the better
you can develop your vocabulary and your
expressions and you talk about different
topics and that's exactly what happened
it's not about the quantity of people
you know it's about the quality of
people you can stick to four or five uh
six interesting people i'm not counting
them it doesn't make any sense even one
can make a huge difference depending on
how but as i said before
we are all the sum of experiences in
people so the more people you talk to uh
the more
variety of actions and expressions you
have
sticking to some people as a core i
always like
absolutely and you know a comment that
or something i can say about you know
the way that you
speak spanish for example is you use
lots of different expressions and you
use words that
you will not find in any textbook you
know you only find
from
native speakers and so this is a result
because this is something i think that
surprises a lot of native speakers and
when people listen to you speaking in
languages and so this is a result of the
the depth to which you have you know
made connections with native speakers
and so this is just a snippet to uh
of a discussion that we are having for
my podcast which is the language is
culture podcast and so if you want to
find out more about you know this topic
about you know how we can make languages
part of our life how we can connect
language to culture and how this can
revolutionize you know the way that we
learn languages then make sure you come
over to languagesculture.com
and check that out um thank you for your
time today luca and we will catch you in
another video and in the podcast thank
you for watching ciao
you